so it's hard to believe in the middle of
the worst drug drug epidemic in our
history which is destroying cities and
killing hundreds of thousands of people
the Bible station will be promoting more
drug use but they are open-air drug
markets in our big cities they call them
safe injection sites they even at one
point sent crack pipes to crack addicts
they haven't done is encourage addicts
to stop using drugs which a normal
person would do immediately you do that
with your own kids
Jackie Berlin is trying to change that
she's co-founder of Mothers Against drug
deaths and she joins us once again
tonight Jackie it is great to see you so
can you just in the clearest terms give
us your message for the bide
Administration in the face of this
my message for the Ministry registration
is to
not allow
safe injection or safe consumption sites
in the United States
and to spend more money or more
resources on addiction and Recovery
Services we keep
in the United States we're doubling down
on addiction maintenance and we're not
putting our resources into recovery and
treatment which is exactly what we need
to be doing
no loving parent would ever do that to
their own child Joe Biden had a drug
addicted son who we all hope is better I
don't think he did that with his child
you would never do that if you love
someone encourage them to keep using
drugs why do you think they're doing
that
I honestly
I'm not sure I'm hoping I'm appealing to
the president as someone who understands
what it's like to have a child that
struggles with addiction for him to
appeal to the Department of Justice and
attorney general Merrick to turn down
these safe um
consumption sites
and to turn towards more recovery and
treatment many of the cities in our
country are lacking services to help our
homeless mentally ill and drug addicted
population it's very frustrating that
they continue to put resources into drug
maintenance and my son is a victim of
this in San Francisco
and I my greatest fear is that they will
continue in the way that they've been
going and continuing to enable my son
he's basically in bondage because they
give him everything that he needs to
stay addicted
but they don't have the resources to
help him get well and I don't want to
see this multiplied across the United
States and if we do yeah if our
government if our federal government
decides to move forward with safe
consumption sites we are going to see
more deaths
it is bondage and I appreciate your
calling it that Jackie thank you and
good luck
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight